just as you are fighting for your
families
my husband our family and the people in
this administration
are here fighting for you first lady
melania trump closed out the second
night of the republican national
convention on tuesday
with a speech in the rose garden outside
of the white house
in front of a small crowd of people that
included her husband
president donald trump and unlike the
speeches from the first night
melania spent more time praising the
president's accomplishments and
less time attacking democrats he loves
this country
and he knows how to get things done
as you have learned over the past five
years he's not a traditional politician
he doesn't just speak words he demands
action
and he gets results the speech was met
with a lot of love from conservative
fans
while some outspoken celebs slammed the
50-year-old for her support of the
president
bette midler tweeted in part quote she
says it feels like just yesterday they
were at their first convention
maybe to you mel for the rest of us
every day has been a horrible
slog through the ninth circle of hell
then there's alyssa milano who wrote
quote
just a reminder melania trump doesn't
care
yeah with that tweet she included this
throwback pic of melania in 2018
wearing a coat emblazoned with the words
i really don't care
do you some people also criticized
melania for speaking to a crowd where
the standard coronavirus precautions
like
six feet of social distancing and
wearing a mask were
seemingly not taken into consideration
no matter the amount of negative or
false media headlines
or attacks from the other side donald
trump
has not and will not lose focus
on you the night also featured notable
addresses from vice president mike pence
and trump's youngest daughter tiffany
this election
i urge each and every one of you to
transcend
political boundaries this is a fight
for freedom versus oppression for
opportunity
versus stagnation a fight to keep
america
true to america and the whole thing was
celebrated by conservatives
for showing a more relatable side of the
modern republican party
kirstie alley tweeted that she liked
getting to know these conservative
americans
adding quote pretty nice smart
compassionate crew
i'd say proves there are a lot of good
people out there who shouldn't be
overlooked or chastised because of their
politics
on the other hand many thought the night
was a bunch of bs
it was crazy wanda sykes joked quote i'm
playing a drinking game
do a shot when they lie bad idea while
ariana huffington wrote
thoughts and prayers for the fact
checkers out there tonight
god bless you all your families and god
bless the united states of america